Wes how you doing I'm good how you doing
Morgan
I'm doing awesome I love your character
Jamie I am definitely one of those fans
that feels bad for Jamie how much should
we worry about him this season
well I think you should always worry
about Jamie
both in the sense that you care about
him and maybe be a little bit cautious
about him I mean he does kill it's true
maybe there's something wrong with me
that I still feel bad for your character
even after season four there's this
incredible moment at the end of season
four where Beth tells John we own him
now in reference to your character how
much does that play out into season five
when it comes to Jamie and Beth that's
exactly where we pick up Beth owns Jamie
she's got him under his her thumb she
has checkmated him which is something
that's never happens to him and he that
that alone has broken him but yeah they
own him they've got him to rights and
and you know what she made him do though
and now any hope of Love or
reconciliation Jamie might have had for
her which I think he had over she didn't
have for him that's gone and now he's
got his own hatred for her yeah so the
she's got him he's got him but you know
I think Jamie's just a Boiling Pot now
he's got no out so he's just angry and
he's just doing and waiting for his
moment oh I oh I love that it's also so
much fun too because we're going to be
seeing Jamie work very closely with Beth
and John now how much fun is that
playing scenes with those guys
um it's a lot of fun you know we have
great chemistry together and we've done
this for so long that you know it's it's
also Taylor wrote some sort of not
lighter scenes but they you know they
had a bit of humor to them and that was
that was fun for us to all dude because
we're usually all yelling at each other
or crying
so you know it's been it was nice to
have a scene like that and it was really
quippy and fun so um that's been great
but you know don't let it deceive you it
is not that's not how it's going to be
the whole time I love that uh you know
at the end of uh the first episode of
season five you know so much is going on
everything was good and then boom
something very shocking happens at the
end obviously I don't want to spoil it
for anyone but what was your reaction to
that episode
I I you know I just saw it last night
and it was just um wonderful I just
thought the episode was so good and all
the actors were great and yeah I even
though I knew what was coming it was
still striking and shocking and and I
I'm excited for people to see what I'm
talking about but it's uh um you know I
was really impressed like our quality
just gets higher and higher it seems and
everyone just gets more committed to
maintaining that yeah aside from your
character do you have a favorite
character that you like watching when it
comes to this show
I loved Gil Birmingham playing Thomas
rainwater I wish I had more with him you
know he's a great guy and he's a great
actor and I love that storyline I love
that I got to do anything with him
before but I miss working with him but
really all of them I mean every one of
the actors brings something special it's
very it's one of those moments where you
just got you know
Taylor really knew how to put it
together and everyone everyone's so
unique and um strong so I love watching
everybody
that's awesome how much fun I think is
the right word to use is it playing a
character that generates such extreme
opinions from people people are like yes
I love Jamie or no I do not like Jamie
it's the best it's you know I I just
love it I love it I love the I love the
things people say to me it's never
anything weird or anything it's like
therapy they wanted to have therapy with
Jamie you don't want to fix them or or
get rid of him but you know like even
the ones that hate him though they have
there's something about the way they say
they hate them that makes me feel like
yeah I don't know if you actually hate
him
loves to hate him yeah exactly if I love
it it's a dream come true things like
that because I like complicated
characters I want the challenge of
playing somebody who's dual you know
desires even so it's just it's a great
guy to play well you're so good at those
characters I mean I was really looking
back at all the movies that you've done
uh you've definitely done some of my
favorite movies it's really amazing
seeing you know now with you in this
show uh did you know that the Four
Feathers it came out 20 years ago this
year
foreign
that's crazy yeah I haven't noticing my
grays a bit more so yeah
hey you pulled that off well you know
I love seeing you and Heath Ledger in
that film together when you think back
on that movie how special is that
experience still for you oh it was great
I mean I love period pieces too and
especially at that time that was
something I was really hoping to do more
of yeah they don't really they were they
stopped to him soon after that so much
but um
I I it was great because it was all
practical too we didn't have any green
screen and we did these giant battle
scenes that was fun but also the
the writing was great and it was good
and Heath was is an amazing actor and I
just I I knew I was going to love
working with him and we got close and
that was a very important time in my
life to to have someone like that and um
yeah you know and I loved the challenge
of playing that role I thought it's been
done before and better so I you know at
least wanted to try to get close to
Ralph Richardson if I could I don't
think I did but you know I liked having
that challenge at a young age no you're
so good in that movie uh just as
wrapping things up how do you describe
John Dutton uh as Governor this season
terrible
yeah you want running your stage
that's amazing Wes so nice getting to
talk to you honestly I love Jamie so
much so I can't wait to see what happens
I appreciate you thank you so much
thanks for your time you're awesome